hello their resignation of Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch from
new rock stars
Joker ending explained hidden evidence a
final twist revealed new rock star has
been one of my favorite YouTube channels
Joker being one of my favorite movies of
the year check out her non-spoiler and
spoiler talk where we of course talked
about the ending as well but you know
they always had these like theories that
I've never really considered or pondered
so it'd be interesting to react to and
then talk a little bit about what
they're diving into let's find out shall
we
also I was on movie fights recently
where I pitched my idea for Joker yet
though not say the movie hasn't stopped
most people quickly forming an opinion
about it okay Joker ended with its
violence antihero lead or the flesh but
the kind of mixed victory after a
lifetime of abuse Arizonan finally gets
the shot that is favorite late-night
show we're on live TV he confesses to
murdering three Wall Street Bros jacks
guys who's got the Society and he shoots
not himself as various moments
throughout the movie for Shadow Man he
would but he sued that Robert De Niro's
worried frequent in men bring this life
face yeah yeah I love it
wanna be just like him you go our third
firing a small a Batman origin down to
the snap to make it make us smile even
wider but here's where things are weird
that's what he did
but we come from Arthur's victory dance
oops
or this trail in a mental institution
the psychologist asks him what's so
funny
and he just smiles and says you wouldn't
get it then come to Arthur stepping down
at the facility hallway leaving the
bloody footprints behind implying he
murdered that psychologist and then the
orderlies came around when I don't see
it how does this Indian reframe the
entire Joker film as you know it I'm
gonna break down the deeper meaning of
this final scene here we go Joker's
ending it explained so there are two
ways that you can interpret the final
act of Joker one is a literal
interpretation of events Arthur's like
clown separate from the mental illness a
pathological actor who commits murder he
of one point believes his father is
Thomas Wayne but then he learns his
mother lied about that and actually
adopted him allowed him to be abused
suffers from the mental illness of a
pathologically thank you Rose was right
that kills the wings and it's up
incarcerated you can see that as your
Joker origin story there's some key
moments those depictions are revealed to
me by club-style subjective fantasies
the first example happens very early in
the movie Arthur watches worry Franklin
Show then the camera slightly cuts to
the inside of that studio with Arthur in
studio audience know flourishing
transition no pushing the markers eyes
no I can we found thanks a million down
memory it's just blink and we're there
as if we're cutting from scene to scene
Murray notice this Arthur's shrill laugh
any signals now he complements him
Arthur stands in the crowd that talks
about his life the crowd affectionately
approves of him worried even invites him
down to the stage he hugs them he says
that he wishes he had a son like him and
of course the fantasy
[Music]
this fantasy is a cruel bully who plays
the video will be clearly ill Soglin
kana can mock him on national television
think about it no Apple Bowl late-night
host in real life would pull that kind
of dick move like Jay Leno kind of a
dick behind the scenes Letterman had
some awkward moments I guess Johnny
Carson probably have some low blows at
Bros but on their own shows where
they're trying to come off as likable
and mainstream any more realistic than
the version and workers dream scenario
the others unreliability pertains to the
character of so played by ZZ beats
Arthur and Sofia meet weekly an elevator
or building yeah no one knows how to
pronounce her name
saucy saucy Bates relationship that
makes zero sense after killing the bros
he knocks on her door still in clown
makeup implants and she's cat was it
like working on the matrix mr. Jackson
their past moments together to reveal
that Arthur was alone for all of those
moments so along with these obvious
inconsistencies other elements in the
story - Savannah like palace Parker it
would get so close to the Wayne family
estate put his fingers in Bruce Lee now
how is this string being able to
overpower through agates outward
pennyworth a former british military
officer latrine bodyguard badass
Arthur even casually sneak through a
heavily police protests to a secured VIP
benefit plot and the theme of
invisibility
there's anarchy without any defined
backstory to make a feel for him even in
the three most consider closest to a
drug or origin Eleanor's The Killing
Joke Joker is like like a struggling
comic but it basically ends with the
Joker implying that actually that was
[Music]
people to get he gets to create the
Batman random the Batman creating the
conditions for joke resistance Gilbert
gets to destroy it Bruce Wayne's life
indeed a spark ignites off the viewer
you can read Joker as a nihilistic
revenge tale or that feels off to you
it's also okay to just read the movie as
a leading fantasy that cracks a smile
from a broken man but hey that's just my
explanation do you think Arthur's life
story was real maybe a mix
I'll go 409 now so did I miss we should
remind the reaction they should have way
more like the best channel when are they
going on tours what I know no do I need
to pledge new rockstars
you do get that 9 497 not what are 407
so you were off by 90 my bad I'm still
close actually we're both wrong in the
video it says 408 and as of now there
are 498 so go new rockstars man this was
cool I've heard shades of these theories
before usually from just like a headline
or a question but I haven't really heard
any of the deep dives into it I've just
heard people talking in public and I've
heard yeah just like so many
interpretations that all amount to this
scene it's a fantasy because this yes
and it's really this most reason when I
heard is that every scene with his mom
she's actually yelling and berating him
but he's just imagining that she's very
sweet oh oh that's cool that's really
cool I I like it the matically I don't
know how it works logistically to me I
when I said mix as I'm like maybe this
is just the way Arthur remembers it
going down or like his perspective on it
yeah as opposed to how it all really
went down I think that that ending is
the spinning top from inception we're
supposed to assume that most of these
things in some way happened the problem
for me with the whole fantasy aspect of
this is that once I start entertaining
it beyond the things the movie makes
very clear our fantasies like his moment
with Murray and his relationship with
the woman down the hall those are very
clearly fantasies and if we just start
taking the rest of it as a complete
hallucination or it undercuts the
fantasy elements of the movie and then
it just makes the whole movie weightless
almost yeah you see I actually don't
believe any of this is fantasy even that
whole thing about what I was saying with
his burst
active that was me saying the most I
could believe it at would be that like a
unreliable narrator who misinterprets
context and not as dynamics yeah yeah
but those things still happened yeah I
am the viewer of the former that he
started this video off with of someone
who just bought it as this is the linear
fashion of how all this went down and
that this is not something completely
made-up I feel like the the point is
that the magic is supposed to be around
the edges we all know that the Joker's
background is multiple choice and so
you're supposed to wonder and for me I
feel like it's almost kind of a mistake
to put that in the foreground well Todd
Phillips himself has said that he's
shown this movie to several people like
before was ever released and everyone
has their own take on what the ending
means he said that he wants to like wait
a while before he says his perspective
Laurie gets fed up and tweets it yeah
you wanted to give it some time do that
kind of traditional director thing where
people have their own interpretation of
the ending but then down the road they
reveal how huh he's not a reverend
exactly something like that
to me that some of these things I think
are just chalked up to getting the plot
going because the fantasy element with
the Murray thing like that the whole
point would like what you were talking
about what the fantasies was to
differentiate between reality and
fantasy the whole thing with Bruce Wayne
people talk about how cool the
switcheroo is the fact that it's Joker
who was responsible for creating Batman
and everyone always puts it in that
context but in the movies context let's
say that is what Arthur Fleck is
laughing about is Arthur Fleck laughing
about how he created Batman or how he
essentially really screwed over his
younger half-brother you know because I
thought this whole thing was there's no
Batman does that mean Joker knows who
bad Mike no one's been raising that
question because everyone puts it in a
joker create a Batman that's why he's
laughing like well actually if there's
no Batman he's laughing because he was
able to rob his younger half-brother
they're not look at it in a movie
context at that point yeah he was
basically able to give him a similar
experience yeah he's in work
he won't entirely know the truth and
he's now orphaned
yeah I'm subject to whatever the system
has for him and as well I think the
audience perspective of
snowing he created Batman is cool but
what's Arthur flex perspective in that
moment that's what I'm more amused by
yeah in the moment I took that almost as
like a fourth wall break because that
whole ending coda is very fantastical as
compared to the rest of the movie it's
very ethereal everything's white it ends
and maybe even pulled scooby doo totally
cartoonishly and so yeah that seems like
it exists on a different plane for me
than the movie I don't know maybe it's
many years later and Batman exists now
and he's like maja so he's my baby so
you know he knows he didn't look that
much it's one of those things where I'm
basically leaving you alone an orphan
just like I was you know yeah yeah and
that even though I didn't do it my
movement this this thing that your
father has been trying to squash out and
led to you having the same fate as me
right right and I think it is meta in
the sense that I'm sure it's
acknowledging the whole Batman created
the Joker it's great Batman as much as I
love Erik Bosse
I can't give him the whole thing on
Alfred with the military background
because that's in the comics lore but
this movie clearly takes creative
liberties and there's never a portion in
the film that goes out of its way to
specify that this Alfred has a military
background and todd phillips has said
we're not drawing from any specifics
with this and so if ever there was an
Alfred I shouldn't assume is just a
badass probably this one yeah that's why
I haven't watched Easter Egg videos on
this that are gonna make all these
comics reference tie-ins like the hidden
easter eggs unless he's pulling the
ultimate trick todd phillips has really
gone on record on syllabuses the joke
yeah he's really gone on record saying
he finds that like ridiculous pretty i
forgot what he said but he was debunking
the law idea he hates the the concept of
putting these comic easter eggs in
movies he didn't do any of that so
that's why i'm watching those videos but
the ending is something work literally
there's a specific meaning he has to it
so that's why i find the theories on
this very fascinating i saw a tweet the
other day that said I forget which movie
it was referencing but it says something
ending explained and then the following
line just said all those people worked
on the movie and that's all I think of
now because this just this title like
ending explained is like the most
popular title now on you to anything so
that's what I think of now have you seen
those memes going around those on those
fake Joker references you haven't seen
them the others so funny in Joker 2019
we see Arthur fly kill people this is
the subtle reference to the trajectory
they're connected definitely they're
definitely related for those who didn't
catch the reference I have seen they're
basically all these people who are
making these hilarious reference music
there's so much of these Easter eggs and
references are such a BS you know I
based on the Joker but sort of only a
little bit because now King of Comedy is
back people know what that movie is now
and so I made a combination of Tom
Hanks's David s pumpkins from SNL but
with Rupert Pupkin 's head and that's my
contribution yeah to the world of Comus
that's it people comedies over with
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell and we'll see it The
Improv Hollywood I'm explaining it is
not as good as just haven't pulled it up
on this massive computer but it's too
much of a hassle to Google and you know
John gets self-conscious when the chair
Wiggles or I'm just lost in the moment
now look how quick he was to defend
himself pick on his insecurities I might
be doing that as possible alien reminded
me of like a face face hugger yeah all
you need is a tail I don't know what
we're doing guys this really happened
stop theorizing none of its real the
movie means nothing that means
everything all of your corrects well
cool that was fun that was fun still new
rock stars now pledge to these guys yeah
subscribe to the shop you haven't done
so already you can subscribe to our
channel click that notification bell you
can check us out on the world of things
that happen to god world the morgan
corner Brian before we end this video
likes to give a page in the day shot to
a man named Scuba Steve scuba Scoob last
month we missed your shout out and then
you stayed pledged that's a sign of
loyalty that's also a sign that you
understand that we are not perfect and
occasionally make mistakes we started
off this month with giving you a shout
out the first of October and now here's
your second shout out to shout outs in
one month to make up for last month I
hope you appreciate this scuba you mean
a lot to me you've done this country a
great service and I appreciate how
you've decided to triple your pledge
going on record I'm posting the receipt
online thank you for
Green to do so hopefully you don't feel
manipulated by this shout out or
pressure to actually do that because
actually this shout-out is a twist
ending and actually none of this video
even happens it's already happening in
your mind the whole video has been your
shout out that reaction you know it's
part of it you didn't get it